Hello. Welcome to Michael's Better Business English.
This month, we're looking at how to lead a meeting.
Now of course, this can be difficult in Japanese as well as in English.
There are three key things you need to do to lead a meeting successfully.
First, keep the meeting on topic.
Second, shorten overlong discussions.
Third, resolve conflict.
How can you do this?
Well, for keeping the meeting on topic, it's very useful to have a written agenda.
Then in the meeting, you can refer to the agenda and stop people from getting sidetracked,...
...going off-topic.
We often use that expression, "Let's not get sidetracked." in a meeting...
...to keep the meeting on topic.
Second, shorten overlong discussions.
Here, it's very useful to refer to specific times,...
...such as the end time of the meeting or deadline,...
...to help people keep focused and avoid wasting time.
Third, to resolve conflict.
Here, you should stay calm, be neutral and move the discussion on.
Maybe move on to a less controversial topic or a different item on the agenda,...
...before going back to that original item.
Or even take a break.
That can let people calm down and relax.
So, use these techniques to lead a meeting successfully.
Thank you very much.